in 2016 but Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama said it was impossible to hack
American elections today though Hillary
Clinton accused President Trump of quote
surrender to Russia with whom she
apparently thinks were at war by not
doing more to stop Russian interference
flee brains is a longtime Russia hunter
an enemy of the Kremlin also a former
Hillary Clinton father he worked with
her at state and other places he joins
the snake so Philippe how was Trump like
what exactly specifically should Trump
be doing against the Russians right now
well let me try it this way
let's forget about 2016 let's assume
that he won 50 states 535 to zero she
came out of her voting booth and said
you know what he's so great I voted for
nothing happened in 2016 let's assume
for a moment that Donald Trump's CIA
director his Director of National
Intelligence and his director of the NSA
testified before Congress and told him
presumably that North Korea was
attempting and planning on disrupting
our elections in 2018 as a precursor to
2020 and they were doing so with the
intent of disrupting the incumbents and
they might hurt House members who are
incumbents what conversation would be
having that I think yes I would say I
would here's like I've been here most of
my life I don't really care what a lot
of people Washington state because
they're dishonest and stupid before mine
circulate are you really telling me that
Russia which has a contracting economy
and population and position on the world
stage a single military base outside his
own borders is a graver threat to the
United States than China or even well
first of I don't I don't think it's
whack-a-mole they could both be
significant adversity at all we're
sucking up to China every our business
sector or an entertainment sector a
political sector all kowtow toward China
we're not not defending China I'm just
saying like what we're hearing from the
Democratic Left is that the existential
threat to the country is from Russia and
the facts don't show that it's insane
actually the intelligence show and its
intelligence presented by Donald Trump's
appointees Republican appointees that
they are going to interfere with our
2018 how exactly are they going to do
that they've done a number of ways first
of all we've now learned that they got
into the registration rolls of seven
States prior to election so how do you
put how do you imagine I mean how did
they get into Sony I mean the North
Koreans gotta deal it so it's like a
serious question I mean you and I can't
talk about how so no but that one
doesn't hack anything Democrats have
pushed after after talk about two people
who took out against foreign hacking
China is the primary what should we be
Venator we never mentioned that
Democrats have pushed for years online
voting because they think it will
increase their share of the turnout
because it makes it easy and their
voters don't like to get out of bed and
go to the polls so how can they stop
nodding but I don't agree okay how can
they still be pushing for online voting
if we face this hacking threat from
foreign countries why wouldn't I don't
think this how simple is online voting
we are who in the United States is in
charge of protecting us against China
interfering with our elections even if
it's hard even if it's gonna fail who's
in presumably you would think our
captains of industry of entertainment
Silicon Valley our military was in
charge at fighting opioids I don't know
I mean Eileen song way okay why wouldn't
there be a White House coordinator what
would he do I guess that's that's what
I'm say she okay well I'm actually use
that the broadly accepted pronoun that
can stand for either one but let's just
say it was Mike Pence for a moment right
what he would do is he would do a number
of things first ill he would take a
whole-of-government approach but
specifically you hit a good point which
is that this also involves the private
sector this involves Facebook this
involves he could bring people together
first thing you would do is you would
say no electronic voting because it's
vulnerable to foreign hacking yet
Democrats are pushing electronic yes you
would know I have better sources and
also I have common sense with Trump's
Paul which tells you that any system in
which electronic beam it transfers
between two points is vulnerable to a
cue but all voter roles are electronic
all right okay but voting itself in
states with paper ballots is safer than
those that have electronic voting it
Democrats are pushing for electronic
voting even though they claim Russia's
gonna hack the election how could that
be I think we were talking about know
what's happening know to the cyber
aren't our Democratic vulnerability that
argues Zuma that argues to the next
hundred years to use paper as opposed
yes to our face
voting systems are because I'm hanging I
gave you a specific thing you know but
hacking a hardened our democracy and you
laugh because it would might hurt
democrat i didn't laugh you said it's
the first thing I wanted to do it's the
obvious thing but no let's set aside
hacking let's just use the word screwing
around or inner 20 seconds hit if it's
interfering yeah let's just say they
can't do it let's just say they're bad
at it let's forget about 2016 I know you
get the people over here in the nothing
burger camp and you've got the people
over here in the double whopper with
cheese camp what should we be doing that
we're not and it seems that the people
in charge of protecting us do not think
we're doing okay well then I think every
Democrat in Congress should have a
Republican to suspend all electronic
voting until we can be sure the Russians
can't hack it that way we can have total
confidence names why do we Bank we just
go back to the fax machine this is a
somber one I'm the one though I'm not
gonna be able all right you do the rush
of the china bowl over here great to see
you always fun